mmm that is good water but I will say
that it's coffee before the show I was
like caffeinate cabinet caffeinated and
then when I'm on the show
well actually I will say this the
caffeine already kicked in you know we
have a cough oh hell show I'll be
talking with you want to be fun we'll be
friendly but the whole time I'll be
thinking if you see my face go in the
room with us my vision lawyer bill
Richman
what about audio way gurbles on the
overlays by the way this is every Monday
Wednesday and Friday at 10:00 a.m. good
and if you're watching right now live at
the blaze you can chat with us of course
we will read your chats as we go on with
the show that's a little there of course
everyone else who's not mug Club $30 off
ladders Comstock club entering the promo
code quarantine that's good through the
end of the month Crowder bits we also
have podcaster sold or free what else
should we get to let me think we have a
lot to get to hear today we have a going
to talk about barack obama funding the
china's huh funding the chinese the
chinese they chine e but he'd um he'd
and finding them after the one-child
policy that they they enforce and I was
there in Cancun Mexico when what's the
name Ted Turner was talking about that
being a good idea wrote it on a bison
and what two bison then he like skis
yeah
[Laughter]
we'll also be talking about Shake Shack
Elan Omar what else why brian Stelter is
a [ __ ] to witness all that but my
question to you is have you guys heard
about the report by the way that Barack
Obama did fund the bat coronavirus lab
in Wuhan I didn't know it at the time
did you think and do you think anyone
the United States has any business
funding any of that overseas these labs
were there doing the bat stuff hey let's
see what's going on at CNN there's a guy
right there who looks like a jungle book
character
[Laughter]
question I think he needs some eyedrops
we are no no it's SOS be off this damn
channel please someone I thought I was
talking with Blitzer check here by the
way do we just just was breaking on CNN
Shake Shack Shake Shack well they gave
back some of their stimulus money right
for small but people got really mad
because there's an one of these giant
corporations get this money so they gave
it back
if I were Shake Shack I would give the
money back and immediately everybody off
just later to split off and be done like
that's it this is so fun when they go
trickle down to the boy we're giving us
the businesses well what do you think is
going to happen if they can't employ
anybody it's nice we check in a
basically a free vacation but you know
what if you want a job when you come
back we do need to support the
infrastructure yeah that actually does
help occasionally they are so screwed by
the way this is virtue signaling at its
finest they receive the ten million
dollar loan which means they went
through the loan process thinking it was
a good idea to get the money in the
first place right have a hundred million
dollars in the bank their latest SEC
filings showed and now they got public
pressure to give it back
they can never lay anybody off again
because then they'll be sorry either way
right right oh you gave the money back
we know you have 100 million why are you
laying anybody off I'd keep the Shakers
but I'd lay off the shacks yeah they
don't see it seems superfluous why and
why Shack in this day and age come on I
used to take pride in marketing you
should be White Castle and we all knew
it was a Shack but now they say Shake
Shack and we all know it's got the new
it's got the new sconces on the wall and
that weird hoarding like a Shack I see
it every single day Church you know they
also have what that Coke machine that
has all of the flavors in one oh no
you're getting the flavors of all the
different yeah you're just getting mixed
nothing's pure these days that is just a
dopamine surge right really I mean it's
worse than pornography and what I say no
chief Shan terrible she's shanty
remember she shows use that word because
it's a small local mom-and-pop shop and
I don't want other people to know about
good lord he's gonna reveal all my spots
I want to give him my after work
schedule Gerald they have no idea where
this place is before we get to brian
Stelter we have a long video
Ilan Omar she now has been found out
that she's been using donor money to pay
the firm that she had an affair with the
guy the guy who owns the firm is the guy
she had an affair with did the guy she
used yeah donations and/or taxpayer
dollars to pay the marketing firm of the
man with whom she had an affair so it's
not enough to be a terrorist sympathizer
now she's got to be a cheating [ __ ] an
embezzling cheating [ __ ] yeah and all
she has is taxpayer dollars monopoly
money at this point right I mean I don't
know I mean it what I mean I guess it's
sort of reverse prostitution I don't
really know how let's talk about the
science all I know is he must be a great
lay your first year anniversary I did
yesterday to prophylactics and a very
long penis mmm no social distancing no
no you don't have any of those coupling
coupling you know like implying you're
good the implication there gives
children nightmares yeah if only you
could fit in Joe Biden sniffing yeah
wait I think I think NAMBLA just on
their new posters we are not all in this
together I want to be very clear about
this
I recognize when people talk about
privilege I I recognize that I am
actually privileged in the sense that
this does not affect me nearly as badly
as someone who has lost their job on a
manufacturing line and lives in a small
apartment I live in a decent sized home
I don't go out a whole lot anyway like
I'm really recluse I'm a homebody this
is far harder
for example for like an 82 year old
diabetic nightclub er this has got to be
hell on earth know him because he's lost
everything he loves so I want to be
clear sorry
in setting up the context as to why and
I feel like I'd pick on him a whole lot
to the point where it's it borders on
bullying but I said I don't care this
borders brian Stelter I saw tweet about
this and then why am i time touching
this because I'm uncomfortable to watch
this that fat gay face is married face
no
brian Stelter talked about hitting it
just let's just play this this is brian
Stelter because he's just like you it's
okay to not be okay right now that's the
main thing I want to say to everyone
watching okay all of us are grieving
whether we sense it or not Austin well
in the past few weeks you were
accidentally greet father or mother
that's how brief words relative others
have lost livelihoods
they've lost access to family and
friends other schemes of things that
make life
Jordi's is that profound loss we're all
grieving do you look at notes I have to
admit to you I have tried to bottle it
all up really I guess I was trying to be
stoic for my wife and kids this Friday
and I hit a wall hit a wall I was
supposed to be finishing my nightly
newsletter that I mentioned earlier but
I couldn't do it I couldn't get it done
I was so gutted by the death toll is
that so Marcus Aurelius ignorance in
Washington my Greece
[Laughter]
lost their jobs it was that mix of
emotions many of you also his airline
the tears the tears we don't talk about
this also when I really I think we
should look into that George Michael I
think we should talk about this really
you think you talk about these
experiencing because we've been doing
stress or anxiety or other emotions as a
result of this crisis
look let's remember we've never lived
through something quite like this we
have nothing to compare this with look
at CNN turn into an op-ed for Teen Vogue
devon Sawa or jtt base time do the
emotions are real everybody they're a
big part of the story I think for me and
someone just put it overlay in there
worth between CNN it says the reactions
were extraordinary actions was
extraordinary I'm still getting hundreds
of emails from readers about this and
notice walking emails nobody physical
letters like someone's walking we have
all these letters for brian Stelter
throw them on the table there's just all
AARP members junk mail No Hair Club for
Men air clothes for them they related to
this one of them was my glass it's okay
to not be okay right now it's wrong
overlay okay so my message to you is
once you're okay right now tell the
truth no no we need to let him make his
place okay to not be okay we've heard it
three times 25 years ago today to date
was the bombing to the Federal Building
in Oklahoma City I thought you've
nothing to compare this
that's a little more severe mostly mean
and selfish they ought to come to
Oklahoma if anybody thinks Americans
have lost the capacity for love and
caring and courage they should ask your
boyfriend what they should ask every
other person on CNN who dogs on a merit
I like every minute you kidding me oh
the Sonny loves Oklahoma right and
America first time actually used the
word Oklahoma instead of flyover right
yeah yeah there's also the disaster
distress hotline the helpline we will
put that number up as well that's his
number call for a good two counts and he
just gave out his emails Oh God
this is alive and we're going to be
accused of daxing right he did it we're
going to be accused of dots on hey guy I
just usually it is of course okay to not
be okay and I understand the irony is
not lost to me when I try to be
authentic and vulnerable at the end of
these shows usually don't do those
credit closes that being said at this
point this is not that point this is I
hit a wall really okay now I would
understand if he hit a wall if you had
Kovac 19 you actually lost a direct
relative of course you hit a wall
because you got all because of the news
that you are peddling all letters and
what's amazing we have nothing to
compare this to I was just watching and
it's a little heavy-handed the plot
against America which is you know if
Lindbergh had won instead of that right
sort of FDR and I can see all the
implications that you know Donald Trump
in America first and he must take the
Jews even though his son-in-law is Jared
Kushner but anyway I feel a pretty good
show but I was sitting there going when
people talk about how this is
unprecedented right the new normal do
you really think and I get it I get it
we need to take precautions like we've
talked about we've always encouraged you
to wash your hands sanitize masse sick I
just think we need to be accurate about
the numbers but it is remarkable to me
to compare this to say how do you think
Americans felt when you're talking about
fear or really anyone across the globe
when France surrendered and there was
the blitzkrieg yeah in London you don't
think that was a little bit scarier
watching the Nazis marched through
Europe knowing that we are next unless
we enter into possibly the bloodiest war
of all time that's what we thought we're
going man
we don't know it's we're gonna lose a
lot of lives you really think imagine
just
yourself in that mindset France
surrenders do you have any idea how
spine-chilling that must have been back
then and you want to compare that to
your coverage of kovat 19 it's not even
close now it's not of course every loss
every life lost is precious we
understand that we always have to to say
this because if you don't say you don't
make sure there's 30 seconds of context
where you talk about all the rows in the
first responders and life loss people
say that you don't care but the fact is
we all know that right let's move on and
being accurate about the numbers but to
act as though you hit a wall because
this is the hardest moment in America
it's not even the hardest moment in in
our lifetimes when you compared to 911
what did he hit the same wall in 2009
I'm sure we can go back and see coverage
of that when 60,000 people died from the
swine flu right right yeah I'm assuming
he at the same wall cuz he said I'm
gutted by the number of people that died
I'm like well nobody wants people to die
but or the 2017 flu year which was like
70 something thousand for flu different
yeah you know you know it's dim I get
that it's hitting you now but I also
don't seem to be very genuine in this as
well he doesn't have anything else new
to say give him a little credit he's run
out of things to say
right and that's breaking sour fat bald
man I mean like sour patch I don't want
those candies I think we should send
them some Snickers I want a sour patch
sour patch from shelters first they're
sweet then they're gay but
rainbow-colored just amazing this is
also a guy too when your talk about
privilege shoes
somehow got in the door by selling
something that wasn't worth anything and
working at CNN like there is no
redeeming value and into the back some
kind of talent I get that at least Chris
Cuomo was like telegenic yeah you know I
mean I you know I've been often told
that I myself have the gift of gab
though I would prefer it were welding
don't get what brian Stelter bring to
the table and now it just seems like
this is woody and I just they hit a wall
like what are you running the Boston
Marathon yeah well are you I had a type
I had to co-sign a newsletter
if this story ended up I used a be test
be someone an automated newsletter and I
just put my name on there I said I can't
that's when the tears came
is he like a first responder is he on
the front lines like working every day
six people helping people like that is
that what he's doing or is he actually
in a steelmaking totally fine okay he
works at CNN it's filled with sick
people but he's already been infected
with that yeah well he was the first
responder in the department store when
Moscow on the Hudson defected yes I'm
kidding love you Joe
that was his gym notice within a few
days of Cuomo kind of having a break and
speaking honestly about his feelings
about CNN and their hyper-partisanship
et cetera you also Stelter saying I'm
hitting a wall I can't do you know this
coverage yeah this crap that we're
peddling he's like actually getting to
me like I can't really spend the dollars
as quickly as I would like right to
cover up for the feelings of hoarding
that I have in peddling I know he just
he's just wishing for the days of Jesse
Smollett to come back to God news all
right we don't really have that much to
offer you here I just wanted to touch on
it let's go to another story here right
now Florida beaches right there reopen
it yeah and it's amazing that this is
controversial as it is I'll get to why
in a second and I want to know what you
guys think
Republican obviously governor De Santis
right now this is being covered
everywhere I think we have a clip
meanwhile some states are already
starting to ease restrictions in Florida
over the beaches like Jacksonville
Neptune Beach in Atlantic Beach they're
open today governor Ron de Santos gave
the green light despite the growing
outbreak but those Beach mayor's specify
they're open for exercise purposes only
and not for tanning nor gathering in
Laurel I'm looking at a fat guy on that
beach was clearly not exercised elders
double social distancing I was
exercising
it just caught me well it's taken
personally like I'm the first Beach they
named open is like is Jacksonville oh
that's where dreams go to die and people
so this is obviously it's been trending
leftist or outrage everywhere on Twitter
that Oh morons in Florida
it'd only be really clear if you go to
the beach you should still practice
certain precautions well what I saw
there were couples we're walking
hand-in-hand as couples do and then
other people maybe for a partner I know
some people are necessarily obeying them
but this is to me entirely reasonable
it's amazing to me that people are
saying these people protesting going out
first off they're not really protesting
going out to the beaches anymore just to
be clear they're actually going out
there and obeying the law but it is
amazing to me that people are upset that
the beaches are open but not upset over
the fact that in New York City the
subways have always been open boys are
rolling Pringles tubes of farts it's
already a cesspit so and by the way they
did say it could be the source of the
virus spread like Subway's absolutely
people say well we need the subways for
the economy in York first off the
economy has kind of stopped a little bit
you can walk you can ride your bike the
weather should allow it if you're an
eco-friendly activist at this point and
if you want to talk about the economy in
Florida it's almost entirely reliant on
waterfront activities just ask the mayor
of Amity so let me get this straight so
large open space is bad petri dishes
underground in New York good yeah that's
what I'm hearing I still has the Dixie
Chicks well you know and every time they
mentioned the subway they talked about
how it's necessary for the economy right
right I'm like I don't understand I
thought you guys just said you don't
care about the yeah right right okay am
I allowed to go for a walk in my
neighborhood because that's kind of like
going to a beach if I'm not announce the
L like in walk a walk
okay whoa what do you what are you
waltzing my walk on are you walking like
this while I wall three four
here's listen three four one there's an
L in the word and I will pronounce it
that's fine I don't I don't I don't
begrudge
there's nothing more than any given week
than the hills that Gerald chooses I'll
write them down in a little notebook and
I
it's the Ellen walk well I will not say
waddle of Bunker Hill history tour there
you go there there's where Gerald died
and their two circuits that's not even a
hill no moat actually a depression in
the ran but I threw myself into just
landfill what is he he chose his rest in
place so it did this is something else
that is pretty important too when you
compare also subways right
subterranean was subterranean sick alien
that's tough by the way Radiohead I
don't know if you ever listened to ok
computer but I always felt like it kind
of gets me a little bit disoriented
Yorke said that was a design of ok
computer was all yes to make people kind
of nauseous like we're gonna fill though
art yeah there's some great songs and
then it's also just a bunch of crap
what are you doing York don't you know
art is supposed to bother you so when
you compare the subway to to Florida
there's also remember Donald Trump was
mocked for saying that you know this
could go away in April now we know that
sunlight actually seems to be killing a
Cove in nineteen according to some new
studies are bad for and specifically
direct sunlight can kill it very quickly
now this isn't entirely definitive but
every study that we have available to us
says that it is helpful so that's a
vampire especially if you look at the
numbers between sort of southern states
and where it's spread more rapidly I
think the average temperature we'll talk
about this a little bit later tonight
I'll do a little bit more of a deep dive
I think it's like it's very low and this
a very low humidity so there is a trend
there is a correlation they look to see
if there was a causation by studying
this virus with UV light directly and it
turns out that Sun kills it so if
anything is going to be open the New
York subway where people relieve
themselves on a regular basis in the pit
of Filth and sadness that is New York
City it just do bad rap or the open air
with salt water and UV light I think
it's it by way are we just now realizing
that there's a flu season flu seasons
not during the summertime haven't we
known this for like a hundred and fifty
years right flu tends to spread during
colder months we've known holiday like I
mean come on this can't be news to
anybody right yeah really
Doc Holliday had rickets yeah who is the
Cardinal at markets I don't know rickets
was vitamin D right i thickets and then
TB was what probably Macaulay Culkin
sorry Minister kokin I hate to diagnose
you with but apparently of rickets can I
get a genuine reaction please oh by the
way South Carolina just followed suit
and said yeah we're opening - really
yeah everybody's gonna open their
beaches in warm climates and be like
yeah so the MSNBC anchor said something
about like despite the growing numbers
like adding one is growing it will
always be growing until there is no more
cases else's
adding 3700 that were never even tested
hey pull some more out from the morgue
this guy but this guy has a knife wound
that's not to take chances a knife had
Cove it I don't know don't put
complications there you go but we have
strong reason to believe it before it
crushes car he went ah Cove it and
that's what caused the crash yeah that's
what causes I didn't even know he was
watching brian Stelter
it is okay to not be okay just like this
is what's the thing with brian Stelter I
was just watching a 34:30 do you see
this on the Duke Lacrosse great one that
actually really didn't be great I didn't
know a whole lot about the actual
evidence of the case and that knife on
knife knife on knife on the guy who was
prosecuting right how he actually was
held evidence and actually lied about
DNA evidence he was disbarred the guy
who actually yeah completely disbarred
like as well here quickly yeah so the
problem with that right is that it does
a huge disservice as we've always talked
about to women who are the victims of a
horrible crime there like rape right
it's okay to not be okay when there is
something that makes you not okay but to
simply say you're not okay because of
the coverage that you have peddled out
there to try and make people think that
it is hopeless that's not an excusable
reason and this is something - this is
this is really true
my therapist just laughed the other
other week because we on some other kind
of going through and I was talking about
how listen as men we don't always get to
we have to control our emotions right if
we're experiencing something that
bothers our wife let's say a familial
issue right they can cry and men can cry
but I said you know like the thing is I
know that me being really emotional
would make my wife feel less stable I
can be sad but I can't fly off the
handle so a lot of the times men they're
like a dog was to go off into the woods
to die we go when we sort of cry by
ourselves
my therapist laughed really she the
woods to die I'm like yeah she's like if
do dogs do that like don't you know they
go and die alone now disrupt the pack
she's like well okay it's a good analogy
we dig deeper into this
there's a few layers when they just heal
up it does a disservice to its there's
nothing wrong with crying as a man right
obviously and that's a very new thing
that really kind of start in the 40s and
50s is false machismo if you look at
Abraham Lincoln you look at George
Washington you go back to any of these
great men they all cried they would kiss
each other on the cheek they were very
affectionate it wasn't like you had to
be a jock or an artist right you had to
be a well-rounded man all across the
board that being said to say that you
hit a wall and you were crying because
of your coverage of Kovan 19 is a gross
disservice to when a man needs to cry in
front of his wife because you know his
Bulldog died or because they have
something going on with cancer right or
even something happening yes a real
issue and and I think you're right like
with somebody like brian Stelter he he's
part of the problem it's like if only if
only we could find a solution to this
problem if only I didn't go in and make
this sound worse every single day if
only I did not provide context for every
single stat that I'm throwing out there
to make Americans feel like this is the
worst thing that's ever happened to us
just don't go to work Brian do us all a
favor stay home you'll feel better
we'll feel better yeah you know what
where's petition done good he'll the dye
on copy for a buck fifty every year
thank you and we talked about the fact
that it's it's been ten minutes of
chloroquine talk on CNN oh really
let me see yeah what's this they're
talking about that song hey that's a
long nose bridge she's a doctor on
Grey's Anatomy and Sandra Sandra Oh so
what's here's what's really interesting
is they've been talking about how
they're moving forward with major pharma
testing yeah they're interested in
seeing the results suggesting um and
that there's some potential that it's
going to be a part treatment regimen
right yeah it already works the only one
and we'll talk about one that didn't was
a Brazilian study where they use far too
much of a dose
and what's remarkable to me is I you
know you see Young Turks and CNN abc1
well this is what we were afraid of what
they're talking about chloroquine of
court right this is what we were afraid
of because there was no evidence it was
effective and now and they cite one
small study in Brazil the only city that
I know of that use significantly over
the recommended dose by the way they use
a high dose and a slightly low dose they
had to cancel the high dose and they
continued with the low dose because it
actually from what we know could be
pretty effective but they had to cancel
the high dose we know they're not
hydroxychloroquine its dose dependent
there is a curve right but it's
remarkable to me that they go there's no
evidence that this works and they go see
this could be deadly they had to cancel
the study well hold on a second what
about all the other studies that were
peer-reviewed what all the other studies
that use the appropriate dosing and
actually sort of eliminate for these
other cofactors that could contribute to
one's health like obviously you don't
conduct a study if you're looking at
people who have heart disease or high
blood pressure that we know that you
shouldn't be using that so there was no
evidence whatsoever and then you have a
one study from Brazil that used too much
and they canceled half of it and you go
now we know for sure what what happened
in the whole evidence yeah scenario I
know that in the pitch meeting for that
when that came across hey guys look at
what I found like everybody's face just
lit up like the grinch like with a smile
great all the way up like yes yes
exactly study and unfortunately people
take me high dose their heart drew for
sizes 10 o the faint-hearted amongst
caused them to burst open but yeah and
all they left in the house was a stint
that was even too small for a mouse um
do we have actually uh right now do we
have a roadie so actually to see what we
got wrong in an update because we don't
necessarily have time to go through all
of the news it is time for the
morning-after with senior News
correspondent rod again
all right mr. Brautigan are you there
sir uh okay yeah Rogan Snoop Dogg I met
McConaughey surprising people Cheech and
Chong know okay Brautigan it's a it's
not no no no it's not their birth it's
not their birthday today Brautigan I
want to be clear about that yeah no they
weren't all born no no okay did you
catch any of the president's briefings
over the weekend they're brought it
senior news correspondent okay yeah
Trump announced a three-point plan to
get America back to work okay step one
steal the underpants step two is a
secret and then step three America
profits no that's no Brautigan that's
actually yeah nope that's from South
Park okay you're confusing the plan with
a facebook meme making yeah making fun
of the PERT thats not news at all I
don't want to get Snoke to what else do
you have
Oh Trump also named his Council to
reopen America it includes dak Prescott
and seek Elliot Chris Cuomo Lady Gaga 90
year-old woman who said she was at a
beer
former W to be rest of the revival no no
no no okay no Brautigan oh yeah no yeah
yes thank you for I appreciate you
listening uh the council that is Jared
and Ivanka okay I want to be clear then
there's the Treasury Secretary the
Commerce Secretary and what you just
talked about as a matter of fact I'm
quite confident those were just people
who happen to be trending on Twitter
well they turn in poor I don't I don't
care I think it's because they're on the
Commission just one last bit of Donald
Trump news this is big now Chris is big
all right he did in fact it's been joked
about but he did in fact give Jill
exotic presidential pardon
smooth Maddie don't have a clip we don't
have a clip no no I wait or I jump at
the clip from Britt nope that Brautigan
that was actually that was a clip that
we did is he talking about the thing we
did in the show that was a bit we did in
the show not pardon too exotic we did a
bit about it on the show no because
someone shared the clip on another
Facebook page okay right
even I are you rot again are you
Brautigan yeah
brought again yes look at me are you are
you drinking already
what is my business that's not how the
plug works I've had enough this has been
morning-after with rotting and everybody
[Music]
hey so why do we have the duck commander
giving us our Judas I don't know is it
really bad I mean he could take over for
Stelter though I think here's the one
thing that when it comes to drinking
Brautigan never hits the wall that's not
he just really hits find another wall
like the juggernaut just the true it's
like Tony Wars really all right let me
see where we are after this I'm like the
kool-aid man yeah
truly by the way thank you Express
expressvpn dot-com slash Carter I think
you get I don't know you get something
off thing that we did on YouTube use
expressvpn we did it reap what was the
reason Retin an extra three months free
off of a USA Brand X Nord security
breach Wow and they didn't let people
this is public news I can say that right
Nord VPN had Ameen so I when I have to
decide between a VPN that has a security
breach and covers it up and one that
doesn't hmm I mean there have to be
other deciding factors but it's a big
one is this a trick question or it's not
a trick question on for you it might be
spread out peon let's get into this
destroying that coffee bag I have
something there we go I had a popcorn
kernel stuck in the back of my every
time oh hey I was brushing I got the
electric brush I got the floss I got the
Water Pik popcorn is a celebratory food
item Steven Mon what did you think when
you watch movies it's like tell me when
are you doing that tell me about it
popcorn eating habits you see this you
pick another Hill to die on it's when I
can eat popcorn exhibit a another tear
why yeah that's true I think we're
running out of letters what do they do I
was gonna ask you what are they do in
court when they run out of you know just
the Alpha the first double a triple a
it's like baseball yeah how how far does
it go like has it ever gone beyond like
triple Z I've seen four weapon in a
trial well we have Z yeah I mean cuz
that's getting about it's only like we
round 100 225 exhibit oh yeah this yeah
I guess so actually well more than the
exhibits they have at the Gerald Ford
Museum right they won't have a three
that's just diapers and that's it go to
your point then I have my point about
the jail for Museum no my point was just
as a terrible hild Gerald I know I heard
it ameno the Gerald Ford Museum is in
Grand Rapids Michigan I lived there for
a very long time and when you thought
you made it up no no no that it sliced
it sliced like a you know a piece of
pizza it's like a triangle so you go in
it's like Gerald Ford and it shows that
you played football in Michigan and then
by the end you walk back and there's
just an Elvis exhibit the picture of
Elvis bar from jail but they don't even
have my guitar like this is less than
Planet Hollywood pictures of like actual
displays and put them up it's sad
because Joel Ford actually seemed like a
really like a supremely decent man yeah
but he was just known for short of the
pardon so there's like a little bit of
time on the pardon and then Elvis and
videos of Chevie chase falling a very
interesting Museum is my point
all right here let's go to this story um
Obama Barack Obama right he this turned
out and you were right about this bill
the lab in Wuhan and I didn't want to
peddle any conspiracies because I know
that will get smoked here in the u 2 we
have to be really careful about that
even though it was necessarily
conspiracy turns out that Barack Obama
actually the NIH under his under his
rule I was gonna say rule that's such a
horrible way his leadership they funded
the Wuhan virology lab that ultimately
leaked coronavirus to the world so
there's we know that there was a lot
going on right now we know that it may
not have just come from a wet market
that it could have come from a lab and
gotten to the wet market but we do know
that the lab has something to do with
this let's go first to president Trump's
response the Obama administration gave
them a grant of 3.7 million I've been
hearing about that and we've instructed
that if
any grants are going to that that lady
was fetching we're looking at it
literally an hour ago and also early in
the morning we will end that grant very
quickly but it was granted it's like a
while ago they were granted a
substantial amount of money we're gonna
look at it and take a look but I
understand it was years ago to throw the
audience's eye he's like a lawyer you
never have question isn't know the
answer yeah
what where'd you hear it I know where
you heard it fat gay shelter but who was
president II know I just I can't after
[Laughter]
tonight when he does if he doesn't want
someone room to play goes excuse me
excuse excuse me that means he wants to
control it when he asked you a question
you damn well better give him the right
answer because he's going to give you
the right answer right better request I
think there's only one more thing you
could have done was like look in the
camera and just mouth don't think I
forgot so there's a new document that
I've been showing the labs they're
experiments by what the bat coronavirus
is concerned officials in 2018 in the
United States stopped sending assistance
over to the lab rightfully in 2018 so
this is also important to note because
this shows a sequence of actions right
of us having funded at some point and
then stopping it at another point and
then okay maybe people wanted to say we
should start refunding it I don't know
exactly what's going on what they're
talking about on CNN right now Italy
considering which antibody tests to add
up for national nobody cares the Obama
administration there's something else
that is really disconcerting to me they
funneled 340 million to the UN
Population Fund that of course helped
with China's one-child policy where of
course women were hogtied and forced to
abort so people don't know this the
one-child policy is basically a policy
in China where they say you can only
have one child
because of population control I was at
the Cancun climate summit this is back
when was called the Kyoto Protocol as
opposed to the is it the Paris agreement
of course of course
here's the court it was a Montreal
agreement Kyoto Protocol and now it's
the Paris Accord have to come up with it
back when was the Cancun climate summit
it was a Kyoto Protocol we did a montage
I once I killed the protocol clear
protocol because that's when I was the
buzzword of the day and they all flew to
Cancun because they couldn't do zoom
meetings which now we know they you know
what I do is do meeting in my office and
I go there in a Hummer is equals out so
I remember Ted Turner they're praising
China's one-child policy yeah it was
remarkable to me for someone that this
this just shows that they are team world
team Gaia and anti human I think we
should keep our stuff clean I think we
shouldn't put you guys know I want to
keep the office Lemaitre polluting when
I see someone throw some trash out the
window I'm furious because there's no
reason to not put it in the trashcan
of course we should do our best to be
good stewards of what we have here on
this earth that being said people take
priority and back with a Kyoto Protocol
when you would have looked at the
skyrocketing energy costs that would
have a package that I did back then it
would actually would be inconvenient for
Americans and it would thrust third
world countries into a plague of death
the likes of which they haven't seen the
modern world because they too deserve
their Industrial Revolution so Barack
Obama supported the one-child policy
funneling in millions hundreds of it
what is it three hundred how much money
over three hundred forty million
I almost said 350 and this on the
YouTube it'll say for all info and co
vid 19 go to Washington Post read
exactly so there's [ __ ] Rhett Rhett
around the same time I guess that this
was happening
I saw a TED talk on population control
and this is I'll tie this back into
China's one-child policy are you watched
a TED talk all right well I went to you
a pastor sigh yeah when I saw it was
happening I I watched one at in a live
audience that was streaming right so
it's all confusing spotted from the
Senate and Sheldon Hill got out the hill
and then he died yeah
and it was a really small high wasn't a
chair at the time and so in this
presentation
they had a chart and they said here are
these different countries population per
kind of family right like how many
people that they have any kids that they
have and what they said is we want to
institute policies that push everybody
into the bottom left which was near zero
right or under one okay and the reason
that I'm bringing this up is because
that kind of policy led to China having
the one-child policy thinking it was a
great idea but it would have the same
effect on everybody else in the entire
room it was applauding yeah this is how
we should in the world basically because
we aren't gonna have enough kids to
propagate anybody's culture anymore I
think you have to have like 2.4 2.5 per
family to do that and everybody was
cheering that here we for I'm sorry it's
really unfortunate for the point for it
is yes they don't get to be a fool that
comes with selective reading midgets
nice how do you choose to give birth to
a [ __ ] it's difficult I guess my point
is that it was a bad idea that the
government was peddling back at yes time
as well so the Obama administration
isn't just supporting the one-child
policy it goes much further than that
and that was just one iteration and I
guess your point just little boring but
um it was a jerk Gerald just learn how
to edit I tried I tried you guys took me
off my game with the whole hill and
dying so Gerald that's a really good
point
so brevity is what you're saying I'm
gonna he is the only president since
Reagan Barack Obama to not cut off
funding to the United populations front
Wow so it's not like Oh everyone did it
and then everyone went along with it and
Donald Trump put a stop to it
Yeah right that would be nice if he was
singularly unique no in this case Barack
Obama is the one who's unique one child
yeah I'll fund it this is it who's that
guy with the the the Bagger Vance
haircut there in the left sorry get very
young Mitt Romney Congress close to deal
for more small business aid well I hope
it doesn't include those pricks at Shake
Shack nope we'd already be done if the
Dems hadn't stood in the way I'd helped
me a Five Guys applies for needs like
all the people at Shake Shack we're like
oh man sweet our payroll it's gonna be
Oh No
not it's gone god it's you guys are not
rehired sorry adios and but forget about
the never-ending peanuts at 5:00 got to
have that ya never knew peanuts what are
you well we do have our next segment
ready to go Oh our doctors we just okay
well then we have some more sort we're
gonna talk about Jane Crenshaw after
that no more watching
but we haven't ready to go on okay so
this is actually a new segment I want to
be really clear for people out there
because people really had a positive
reaction to this guest last time you
know yeah my personal doctor and he
talked about kovat 19 it was a very I
would say it was a very measured
approach and a very balanced approach
where we didn't need to panic but we
needed to take the proper precaution so
a lot of you said we like him we would
like to see him more and so this is a
new segment with dr. Choi that we'll be
implementing we call what's up doc
[Music]
I am a Korean alright dr. Choi are you
there sir yes how are you really
you can sound like you can hear me dr.
Choi well yeah yeah we can hear you just
fine yeah there you go you're looking
very chipper and I know you're on that
you're you're on Pacific Time so I
appreciate you getting up early for us
how was your practice going last time we
spoke with the co vid 19 or you you're
doing well you're keeping safe yeah
we're still kind of semi lockdown so
businesses are open so I mean we are
considered essential so we're open but
I'm not seeing any routine visits right
that doesn't make it you know dangerous
for the patient so we're just seeing uh
urgent business okay and just taking a
lot of phone calls yeah um the patience
and testing some patients are you making
sure that they're wiping off the phone
the phone's after they talk when you
talk to them on the phone do you make
sure that they sanitize the phone
because that's the dirtiest place in
your I tell the cages to sanitize well
that's good that's a good precaution to
take that's why your that's why you're
my doctor
um so you know what we're going to be
doing actually some people here at the
office dr. Choi they don't they don't
have a they don't have health insurance
yet
so actually quarterblack Garrett I
believe right had some questions for you
about a current condition yeah I'm not
sure what it is yet so I'm okay in a
condition that he has and so dr. Choi is
aware we've sent we've sent a picture
dr. Choi believed to his email audio
Wade to his phone to his and a court of
like yeah just give him a briefer here
what it is and we can show it to the
audience so they know well so we're I'm
I'm experiencing some abnormal discharge
from my lower region okay and since this
is a big thing now - as is televisions
with doctors so we want to see yeah
trying to help so uh also I'm having
some severe burning from yeah right and
dr. Troy you do this a lot on skype and
you do televisions like zoom visits with
people especially during this emergency
based on the picture that you have they
and Garret listing kind of some of the
symptoms what do we think is is going on
okay yeah you got the picture yeah okay
we can show it to the audience here real
quick so they can see here's the and he
said a discharge and burning dr. Choi
yeah what do we think might be going on
here really oh wait a second that's me
oh do we know how or what kind of like I
guess what questions would you have for
quarter four Garrett here for that that
might be able to clarify what's going on
infused well does have multiple sex
partners a monogamous are you sure yeah
you're not a swing or anything okay no
no all right he's saying one partner
needs monogamous doctor Choi how long
for as long as ever never had one two
months nope just one just one just one
is there anything else like what kind of
an STD do we think it could be dr. Choi
I'm notwhat quarterback Garrett but it's
um it's around my my anus oh okay
whew saying it's around his posterior I
try to use the technical term for yeah
so is that does that help does that help
hone in on what it could be cause STDs
yeah oh when you wrote there okay okay
usually occurs in people who engage in
anal sex oh okay that's not the case I
don't know about that quarterblack here
okay joy so it your official dag it
seems like you would probably need
doctor you would probably need get
quarterblack yet to come in and maybe do
a full physical - yeah crap I'm gonna
take the history like we're doing
and then examine the patient and remove
the lesion and check worked okay so and
there's a discharge like a biopsy and
then of course if there's a original
discharge then you have to take a sample
of that except where other STDs like a
chlamydia gonorrhea okay
HIV or potentially anal cancer HSV
herpes simplex virus okay that's all
okay and there's a lot of student that
will condyloma also oh wow that sounds
this looks like a halo wars okay oh okay
well we have to blur it for YouTube so
they can't see but that we appreciate
the dust and if there are people at home
dr. Cho who might be suffer because this
is a big part of the show you know we
have a lots of people watching who might
be suffering from something similar what
precautions should they take to avoid
this and and what should they do if they
think they're feeling some of the
symptoms like like quarterblack Garrett
o abstain from sex okay if not make sure
you use your protection okay you know
birth control pills do not put touch
against STDs barrier so physical
barriers a condom okay and to be
monogamous yeah be preservative with
your uh in a sense of helplessness
okay so have one partner and then if you
have symptoms you've got to talk to your
partner's are you gonna actually come
and see your doctor and get tested okay
because you know most common STD in this
country is chlamydia and gonorrhea
chlamydia and then the gonorrhea
so that's what we always check the
chlamydia and gonorrhea together okay
and if you don't treat this in time that
it can actually become more systemic
okay well there we go the guy over here
you can't even get a meningitis you know
between the brain okay just a rare
complication late can happen right which
is very dangerous
yeah so you wanna use it I think I'm
just gonna go ahead and y'all can run
with what your partner's to treat it yes
well I will I promise you we'll have dot
we will have cord like I go in for an
examination
absolutely it's its boss's orders at
this point I'm the shake shopping in the
Shake Shack right now and I'm
determining payroll
we appreciate it dr. Choi quit anything
else that you want to let people know
out there to stay safe with the kovat 19
well you know we're still on a lockdown
I think as a entire country and I think
that is very prudent right now and we
are you seem like we're getting over the
hump but if you're not very careful
right now that we can have us a second
wave right okay so we need to be very
careful in our social distancing social
distancing you wash your hands you know
wear your masks now that you know the
CDC the government said you know the
general public should wear the masks
when they're in a crowded places so wear
the mask and be safe out there and don't
go out unless you have to right and
those same rules should probably apply
to quarterblack Garrett across the board
dr. Troy thank you so much for being
with us we can let him go we really
appreciate it we'll have you back soon
this has been what's up doc
[Music]
Detroit I am a Korean all right I lost a
lot of respect for Garrett I think you
talking about yeah I don't believe any
of those things I think hey Garrett hmm
yeah thank you yes and we love you no
matter what but take the colored bars
off my screen here yeah all I'm looking
at are color bars on my screen because
when I see people calling by Skype and
there's your color bars yeah you know I
want to ask him a question when people
drive around in their cars with their
masks on is that effective all right you
got in your car in the garage drove
somewhere got out for two seconds entire
onna is in the backseat it's it's gotta
be ever known
I saw someone driving and but they were
but then they would take down their mask
yeah beep yeah it was one of those
motorcyclist Matt's really like the
skull and crossbones just you just want
to dress like the bully from Karate Kid
FDA compliance that's the Karate Kid
costume all right by the way hey hit the
notification bell if you are subscribed
on the YouTube and you're watching on
YouTube right now I hit all
notifications because apparently just
the notifications don't mean a whole lot
and of course subscribe on Apple iTunes
I guess they don't do iTunes anymore
Spotify wherever they're so consider
joining mug Club Apple that of cut it
accomplished mclubbe quarantine is the
promo code to get $30 off it's the only
thing that keeps us going as well as
carpets has been doing pretty well for
us lately so we appreciate that okay so
then I guess the last story we should
talk about here is a Dan Crenshaw my
hero was not whooping it man that's your
hero he's doing a fantastic job in
American he's an American seriously not
only does he die in Hills he doesn't
take lifelines when offered them like I
said your hero you but well I mean I
admire him but you started back then my
hero I didn't back down okay
I do like I do how like sometimes we'll
try to try to move on with in child
we'll just bring it right back and then
just like sneak it back in again and
we're like no man I have a few more
points on this
yeah no no no hold on hold on I have a
few more so I have existed AAA are you
into like the gaudy family we were
trying to shave points off this show no
Gerald I would just make it going next
20 minutes a little while longer they
want to move on to something relevant
bacala he's got it over under on likes
and dislikes cover the spread here guys
it's it's a bear market all right like
mobsters know a lot about the world
sports betting yes now he's defending
the mob Gerald you're like the worst
under guys man do you know what the the
I wonder if the mob is really I wonder
if the mob is really pissed about
Silicon Valley because they're
effectively like the new mob right now
when you look at a Google Twitter
Facebook they can just step in and show
your stuff yeah so I wonder if the mob
has their claws into the digital space
at all because that would be interesting
that would be very you think they're
proud like little babies we talked so
fast the mob oh the mob yeah they talk
Silicon Valley so well oh yeah I taught
Silicon guy okay I thought you're saying
like they had babies that they were just
they had and sit there at bay I didn't
know what I was thinking honestly I'm
still distracted by your it hurts just
talking about it monogamous huh okay so
Dan Crenshaw was on with Bill Maher and
um I will say this about Bill Maher um I
don't have a whole lot of respect for
him so there are people who are funny on
the left and like Jon Stewart was one of
them Stephen Colbert at one point was
one of them Bill Maher you see this one
he doesn't have a crowd and I will say
this I've witnessed many time people
who've gone to Bill Maher show and had
to deal with the crowd they are very
much like trained seals I mean not only
every crowd every crowd has a crowd
animator right with an applause sign and
a laugh sign all that they have a
warm-up act but Bill Maher it's very
very clear that you are Team Bill Maher
and not anybody else they're all
provided that they in fact are back
bill Mahr so if like Hesse cutler then
it makes a point that reiterates like
what Bill Maher said okay you're allowed
to clap because she effectively was
reading Bill Maher's points but anything
else not allowed and you see it very
clearly when he's trying to do this
stuff from home now without the audio
because Bill Maher's things yes I kind
of like Janeane Garofalo right it's like
a like men yeah Bill Maher has this rate
does the he does the hand and that laugh
that's his cue and because when he does
this when he says you know and when you
look at Republicans really they're all
closeted homosexual stage people then
everyone goes right but then he does
this to silence and he's like I just
looks kind of Stelter ish and it doesn't
work and so I also think there may be
it's been hurting his confidence yeah I
guess he had Dan Crenshaw on the show
and and and representative in Crenshaw
who's a friend of the show and of course
I want to be very clear representative
Dan Crenshaw a very nice man cordial man
I don't agree with him on everything but
cordial respectful and of course yeah
not a homosexual but you would be
confusing this clip because it amounts
it's tantamount to rape it's very close
yeah I was watching turn away episode of
Oz it's more of a power thing because
taken part like an upstate Maine where's
tool to whiter guys so here is Dan
Crenshaw talking with Bill Maher and to
be clear the context I don't know we
have in the clip Bill Maher said I want
to talk about the issues and stop
covering tweets and stop covering social
media let's talk about what's actually
going on the second that Dan Crenshaw
decided all right let's play by these
rules
Bill Maher tries to zig zag and it
faster than joke and Dinah hill let's
watch there are still people coming in
from charge let me address that because
I know that's that's people are saying
right now but the reality it was about
forty thousand people came in after that
these are US citizens and green card
holders and passport holders being
repatriated US citizens termination
argument then that is not the same thing
it sounds to me like you're fully
agreeing with President Trump on this
when everybody else disagreed with them
if you're saying that you wish
well that travel restriction where's my
applause well you apparently had the
look at me looking on was in charge at
that moment he's already said he
wouldn't have done it he criticized it
as know that he Pelosi actually plays no
display stop he found everyone who wants
a test can get it which is still
completely addictive February clearly
wrong go forward because I mentioned
February 25th the day before prepared
24th that's when the administration
requested two and a half billion dollars
oh sure crunch funding to combat the
virus potential spread of it
what happened right then I'll tell you
because I was in Congress but I know
what happened did we vote on a
supplemental funding bill no did we wait
days to vote no still didn't vote on it
you know what we voted on later that we
Nancy Pelosi the only thing she would
put on the floor to vote on was a bill
to ban flavored tobacco that's important
actually happened it wasn't it was only
a weekly notice by the way they go
fullscreen away from bill right now goal
to make Trump look better is the goal to
get to the truth because there's two
different sets of answers for that well
without the audience someone I don't
know how to answer that and by the way
that is a legitimate eyepatch Bill Maher
he didn't buy that a novelty sex shop I
know you think that he may have after
that sex ed it was just too well you
know cuz the rape so my point is it was
it was as thorough of a debunking that
as you can in the Stan Crenshaw is not
always that way
he's been on our show and I felt like
sometimes he didn't necessarily give the
the answers that I would have liked to
have heard right but this was incredible
because I think this is a perfect
example when you see Bill Maher here
with Dan Crenshaw Bill Maher is used to
this working yeah because he's
surrounded by people that are group
admit work yeah exactly and now you take
those people away because of the
quarantine and he thinks going well
Donald Trump didn't do enough
anyone who has looked at the time anyone
who's followed the time line anyone who
saw Donald Trump present that petty
childish and perfect video at his
presser with the time line knows what
actually happened he knows that you had
DeBlasio and Nancy Pelosi encouraging
people to go out and eat in Chinatown
knows that there was a China travel ban
no is that obviously they were looking
for testing earlier and they were they
tried to send in people
from the CDC they know this but Bill
Maher wants to focus on mean tweets and
it works with the people around him when
presented with evidence they're
irrefutable evidence you may not like
Dan Crenshaw you may prefer bill maher
it is undeniable
in this instance that Dan Crenshaw was
correct yeah
and Bill Maher was incorrect absolutely
and Dan Crenshaw is point is that we
were working with information that we
had there's this there's this big thing
out there right now that everybody knew
all this was gonna happen right in
February everybody we lost February this
whole last month and he made this point
it's like people didn't like Italy
didn't start closing their country until
later in Spain didn't do it until later
as well like mark he didn't know exactly
what was going on we were gathering
information and trying to do everything
we could to prevent it spreading with
what we knew but that was it what do we
have like 125 cases well well then they
try to slip it and they go well that's
just because we can have testing okay
the point is when you say well why
didn't we shut things down earlier
because there were only a hundred cases
or maybe at this point they're depending
while you're talking the timeline no
deaths or even even if there are a
couple hundred cases even if there are
thousand cases do you think that the
American public would have stood for a
shutdown yeah at all and then they they
respond with well that's because enough
tests that's irrelevant to the point
that you were saying we should have shut
down we only had a hundred cases that we
had tested for sure
would have been nice had we had tests
earlier would have been nice had we
partnered with private industry earlier
as opposed to relying in the CDC would
have been nice if we had private
industry stepping up and making masks
and protective gear and ventilators like
they're doing now when the government
has screwed up so the private sector is
picking up the slack would have a nice
for all of those things absolutely but
that's not what you said you said why
didn't they start a quarantine or
stay-at-home order earlier because there
were only a hundred cases at which time
your folks were saying go on down and
eat cat and a stick in Chinatown yeah
and right after President Trump did the
travel ban Nancy Pelosi introduced a
bill that would have prevented him from
introducing anymore bans I don't know if
you remember that Oh like the no ban
bill it was like what right you serious
well and keep in mind to again they're
playing politics with this where they
thought they could seize upon the travel
ban from China trying to compare it with
the Muslim ban which by the way was from
seven countries doesn't need a Barack
Obama so they were gone oh I know we
made this sound like a Muslim ban when
really it was a temporary moratorium
until coming from countries that were
hotbeds for terrorism we were able to
make that work let's do the same thing
and try and tie this China ban right now
to uh xenophobia
as Joe Biden said Joe Biden said he
wouldn't have done it he said that he
thought it was racist it was xenophobic
they tried to present a bill to stop it
because politically they thought they
could damage Donald Trump screw up you
screwed up you screwed up you screwed up
and your constituent screwed up they
trusted you that's it end of story let's
move on it is remarkable to me when I
tune into these leftist shows like
that's not the timeline at all no no and
I just appreciate the Dan Crenshaw did
this he did another video as well I
think that just kind of had the same
kind of points in it I think that's why
he was so well prepared and he just
didn't stop he wouldn't let Bill Maher
chime back in because he's like look
you've got to say this this entire spiel
on what's been going on none of that's
true right here are the facts I'm just
laid out very clear I do like the idea
that you know Bill Maher being kind of
stripped bare of the audience to jump in
and laugh because all it would take for
him is to do the hand flip yeah even
when someone else is talking and the
audience laughs yeah and cuts off the
speaker breath but not in this format
doesn't as well he can still cut it
that's another thing too if I had a
producer at Fox talk about how funny
they thought Chelsea Handler was I was
like no that's just not my thing I
remember talking about cuz at the time I
thought read I was a great show and
talking about how I really wished it you
know had more viewers and had had more
kind of promo behind it this person was
to Omaha they thought Chelsea ham it was
really funny said well you know the
reason comedians don't really respect
Chelsea Handler and not only comedians
but actual hosts out there in
entertainers is because she would tape
you know an hour and run a half-hour and
it's the same thing with Bill Maher and
will tape and then I'll edit it down and
so I do think that everybody out there
if you're going to do a mainstream show
it's particularly front of a live
audience where you'll have control over
the cameras you should have some kind of
a recording device if you're in a state
where it's legal because they do try and
catch you and change the context and
that just doesn't fly anymore you can't
do that when he's on a Skype and if you
try and I think he probably would have
wanted to do it but had he done it he
probably knows that it's not all that
hard for Dan Crenshaw to hit screen
record even if the depth obviously
challenges he can still find that but he
just needs to put it in dark mode he
does definitely easy by the way don't
you love that we got in trouble for a
can I say that we got in trouble for
saying that Dan Crenshaw looked like an
angry pirate hold on we force people on
the left I can't remember if it was if
it was Twitter or YouTube but
that was an actual quote he was you mean
when he was on the show oh my god you're
offended for you
Wow you know we also get made fun of for
the jokes that I tell about Asians about
me oh really
yeah it made fun over you get rid the
right no no no get you know people who
are like well you know that's clearly a
violation is your Chinese social score
going down no no it's going up cuz bye
so counterbalance this awesome
counterbalances he was talking about
let's go to some shots before and then
I'll talk a little bit a little bit of
inside baseball speaking about Fox News
yeah so we have a chat from Thad I love
what you guys are doing now that I'm
Mudd Club member I can talk with you
guys when do you see the states start
reopening well they already are
yeah some state really yeah I mean I
think some people again that this is
because of the presentation of the left
and try to make it sound as though it's
a total reopening or a total shutdown
know what they're seeing happening is
beaches where people can go for exercise
they still need to practice social
distancing I mean reuse the refreeze
read the three-phase plant out there
that you can see it's a very very
reasonable approach and you're seeing
this in quite a few states where they
are easing some restrictions for
businesses and then gradually moving to
rather than determining what is an
essential business determining what is
non-essential yeah exactly I just
reverse it I don't care whatever the I
think May first is probably what you're
gonna see a lot of states use that was
the original end of this period right
shutting down to begin with and so I
think a lot of states are just gonna
kind of play it safe for a few more days
and then start gradually opening it in
May first will be the day yeah people
start opening up the day before the day
that people will start opening up yeah
other businesses there's no question
that it's gonna be I mean first of all
you process you've got a lot of
different states that have a lot of
different you know kind of political
purposes and what they're gonna do in
different economies that are affected in
different ways but not only that you
have a vast diversity of you know areas
within the states themselves right the
counties or the cities and when you look
at the more rural areas there's no
reason why just given the nature of
those areas they can't ease the
restrictions a little bit more right but
it requires it requires attention
there's no headlines there's nothing
sexy about saying okay here are certain
areas that we're gonna do and here
certain businesses in certain locations
none of that is gonna be headlines I
know that's gonna be CNN none of that's
gonna be you know everyone panic or
terribly close
he doesn't have time for that he meant
the wall he can't see through the tears
I mean yes and I think you're right
Gerald that by May first you're gonna
see more of those things start to
implement and and what people should not
be looking at is is this a complete open
or not right open right yeah I would
tell you that any state that's not
opening we ain't pull back all the
restrictions everyone go down to your
local stadium and pack in right no one's
doing that no but but you would think
that that's what was happening based on
the way the reporting is go that's a
good point
right we have a related chat actually
Zac from Michigan just just talking
about governor Whitmer he said he's just
curious if I take my fishing boat out
and receive a fine is this something
that they can actually do or is there
any legal action that could be taken for
denying my constitutional right slash
freedom considering we do live in the
USA that is an interesting question bill
what would happen let's say someone took
a fishing boat out and were given a fine
so I don't follow Michigan law cuz I
don't care but but here's here's the
reality right every county has their own
rules and if the rules are there and
they're written and they're clear and
they're being communicated you should
follow those rules here's the practical
effect let's say it's unconstitutional
you and your boat
you're gonna go hire a lawyer and fight
for us read 50 100 hundred $250,000
litigating your right to go out on a
boat maybe maybe not right I mean right
it's a tough situation but that's the
practical reality and the impact of
these laws is you know they'll have
governors and you know County
Commissioners and mayor so we'll just go
well let's just go ahead and write this
law we're gonna write a three-page law
and we're just gonna say nobody can go
out and do this thing without actually
thinking about what the practical impact
of that is so in that situation you
should follow the law and even if you
think it's unconstitutional you're
probably gonna have a bigger problem
just disobeying it and more sheriff's I
would survive you guys flagrantly
disregarding the unconstitutional
regulations from the governor that's the
place where we need to get more
guidances the local politicians we
talked about this before they when they
decide to go in and you know sheriff
says I'm not gonna file the governor's
rule because I think it's
unconstitutional they are putting their
dicks on the line yeah right there in
that moment and saying we're not gonna
prosecute it in this County which is
fine over I can arrest people in this
county they may face consequences they
may be ousted and it's a [ __ ]
position to put sheriffs in people who
did it people who are the kind of police
officers who you want right out there
the kind of and I get it not all cops
are perfect and not all cops are bad
guys let's be really clear about that
they're human beings like any other
profession but the kind of cops who you
want taking that oath are the kind of
police officers and sheriff's that you
see in Leland on is it Manistee county
in other were you in northern Michigan
or them those are the kinds of police
officers you want because they're saying
hey listen I don't want this Authority I
shouldn't I'm not granted this authority
to tell people that they can't use their
fishing boat I'm not going to find them
because I am here to uphold the
constitutional law of the United States
it's a horrible position to put those
kinds of officers the kinds of officers
and sheriff's who we want out there in
when you demand that they enforce
unconstitutional regulations that's it
and that might discourage people from
becoming police officers in the future
who you want being cops you end up with
nothing but mall cops and Renta cops who
are on a power trip we don't want that
we want we want sheriffs who say I don't
want exercises Authority and you know
what some what we call this the the
Batman investigation rule yeah I don't
know if for anyone who follows comment I
was just like running joke oh yeah in
the comic books that they would have a
Batman task force and it would be like
the most junior blind deaf Helen Keller
detective in a room without any lights
and they're like Maura go get them they
don't want to get up and that is within
the discretion there are there is the
ability to say oh yeah we're we're
upholding it I mean you just you just
don't put your you don't you just don't
put your energy right now of course if
you're flagrantly violating the law in
front of a cop now you've put that cop
on the spot right yeah I'm saying right
you don't even giving them an
opportunity to look the other way
exactly and there's a prosecutorial
discretion even at the attorney
yeah the DA's and that kind of thing so
you know what I like about this is
America finds a way to have common sense
even when the politicians and the media
is saying other America right finds a
way well I think that's what you do as a
citizen in these situations you find out
you know no pun intended the hill to die
on right I choose really bad ones you
should probably choose better ones yeah
at some point this becomes something
really go out on the on the lake in a
boat just to protest right
but I don't think we're at that point
yet I think what they did in Michigan
was a great where they drove into the
capital and they just basically locked
everything down they were still social
distancing from one another but they did
something in protest saying hey this
isn't right and also they pushed back
and said look we don't like what you've
done and guess what we're gonna vote
we're gonna vote and we're gonna use
that to get people out of office sit
around that and by the way wade edited
that question it was governor half-wit
mer and he skipped right over there too
funny to say on-air yeah so we yeah we
do have a couple more yeah give me one
more and then I think we have to wrap
this up okay yeah Becky d1 says I want
to say thank you to the louder with
Crowder crew for opening my eyes I used
to be in the Bernie camp a couple years
ago I really appreciate your specific
brand of talking through arguments
thanks from your atheist vegan latina
superfan what do you mean we opened your
eyes which is really an eight
was she a six week old puppy she could
have been maybe we could use some more
vegan atheist Latinas six-week-old yeah
there we go but thank you very much I
appreciate that and that means a lot
thank you guys everyone out there of
course who is oh by the way do follow me
on the Instagram at ladders credit
because I'll be giving away a $1,200 Tim
yes though you are all laid off oh and
this is something right after the show
course this is actually highlighted
something to me when we talk about we're
all in this together we're really not
now we are all in this together as a
country meaning that we are going run
should be doing everything we can to
move forward and support a fellow
American absolutely that being said not
everyone is affected the same way right
we talked about this before if I were if
I were an 80 year old diabetic night
club would be much harder than someone
like me who when I'm done with work I'd
pretty much just go home and I you know
watch my shows so I said I will tell you
this when people say we're all in this
together and they talk about well the
people who are most affected they talk
about race and they talk about people
who might have less money all that is
true people are different demographics
are affected differently but there is
one that I think is being overlooked and
this is something that is pretty
important because I think it shows a
lack of scale a lack of actually
understanding kind of how the economy
works and how it affects people the big
divide this is we are not all in this
together not everyone is a business
owner you need to understand this that
right now you
you were affected obviously as an
employee everyone affected but there is
a business owner out there we went
through some numbers you know like 36
percent of non restaurant or sorry non
grocery but retail related businesses
don't think that they're going to last
these people out there they obviously
they worry about their livelihood just
like you this is I think some people
think that business owners have
stockpiles of cash that's clearly not
the point
clearly not not the case even with Shake
Shack right
they don't have stock piles of cash upon
which they can simply fall back they're
going to lose their living to but they
also have the compression of trying to
ensure that they can provide for 10 15
50 200 people right they've built
something up so that they can make a
living but all of you make a living and
so when people say hey I want to get
mine right now hey this says we're all
in this together why the business
trickle down why not from the ground up
well on a second business owners aren't
all fat cats they're most of them are
certainly not millionaires most of them
actually aren't making much more than
upper-middle class family and by the way
they should be wealthy if they create a
business that adds value to people's
lives but these people will lose their
livelihood just like you will and they
will no longer be able to provide a
livelihood for you moving forward there
is a compression right now we can talk
about minorities we can talk about women
we can talk about old people but
economically small business owners out
there are so disproportionately affected
the amount of stress that they are
carrying right now is not even
comparable to someone who is going to
receive a stimulus check everyone has a
tough time I get it but if you have a
business owner and you have a boss you
think it's pretty good you know what
maybe you should go out there and get my
hug let up we'll don't get mugged but
you know give him a virtual hug hey you
actually appreciate him because this is
some of this class warfare really
alienates people who automatically
assumed to be Daddy Warbucks yeah I
don't think they realize that not only
Shake Shack the business but what do you
think about the guy who's running a
local Shake Shack franchise exactly I
mean McDonald's look how much money they
make sure absolutely coca-cola
absolutely but what about the bodega
owner who sells coke right he employs
three four people he loses his living
and those people lose their living now I
would say this most employers just like
most people most cops are good people
most hosts are probably good people most
government okay there are some
exceptions to the rule but the point is
most small business owners or at least a
comparable portion of them compared to
any other profession are decent people
and they are concerned
of the livelihoods of their employees so
to just tour and feather them because
they happen to have reached the
privilege of running a business that's
not the kind of message you want to send
if you want an economy from hereafter
and speaking that you know I think you
were asking me this the other day Audie
we're talking about Fox News and how
they like Chelsea Handler [ __ ] Fox News
people can ask me was bombshell on these
shows about my experience oh yeah yeah
but Roger he'll yeah yeah do you well
there's not really much to tell the
story about when Roger Ailes made you
put on a blonde wig was a mutual played
played with his navel really get out of
there yeah I hear that I think that's
the Roger Ailes death squads oh no no
so you think people ask me about Roger
Ailes because now he's been a hot topic
I never met Roger Ailes I was at Fox
News for four and a half years somewhere
between four and a half and five years
total when he had it up I I never met
Roger Ailes that's interesting so I will
say this there's someone there who I
have nothing but good things to say
about in my personal interaction she's
the president there now at Fox name is
her name is Suzanne Scott that's public
information she's president apparently
she's been doing a really good job she
was kind of the person who brought me in
there and showed me the ropes and was
really nice was really supportive and
Bill shine was there back in the day I
guess it also got caught embroiled in
some sort of sexual assault scandal so I
I can't speak to all that aside from you
know listen there was the leg chair for
a reason on these shows and the bill
o'reilly thing he did it so but I never
met Roger Ailes and this lady would run
interference for me yeah and then
finally I was going I was pitching these
ideas one of them was to this guy who
really liked Chelsea Handler and they
sort of paired me up with a host to
create a show similar to this show at
this point but then they wanted to
change it at one point there was a
suggestion of monkey on rollerskates
which was like that's horrible that you
came up with that idea
I think monkey I mean a monkey and wrote
really funny but I don't but I don't
want it on the show and then finally she
just sits me down and goes like yeah I
know you even wanted to meet Roger for a
while but it's um
doesn't like you you know I was told he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't get you
and so it doesn't get he doesn't think
you're funny and I was like okay I
understand okay so in other words I'm
not going to meet the person who runs
this network who makes all of these
determinations as to who gets to host as
to who's a contributor because he
doesn't like the very essence of who I
am
so that was my experience and then there
was I'm pretty sure you can probably on
a search and find this you know Dennis
Miller I used to do his show quite a bit
yeah and Norm Macdonald used to do you
know they're really close friends and
Dennis Miller had a bit on Bill O'Reilly
show called Miller tongue and it was
just by the way Dennis Miller brilliant
hilarious it was just an exercise in was
like billowy King let him finish some
material here bill but if you want to go
off and talk about we can do that that's
the cut of your Jim's like okay we get
it bill shut up you're not so they were
all friends and one-time nor up Dennis
Miller couldn't make his segments Miller
time so norm filled in oh boy and I
loved it I adored it if you can go and
search noir MacDonald filling in for
Dennis Miller and of course he's not
Dennis Miller that was a segment
tailor-made for him but Norma did as he
performed as well as he possibly could
he never did it again from what I
understand at most he did it twice and
then I heard through the grapevine that
Roger Ailes really really didn't think
nor McDonald was funny and that was the
greatest compliment anyone has ever paid
me because even though I knew that my
career was at a dead end at that network
at that point I felt like I had some
some kind of a link Norma Donna was a
kindred spirit in that Roger Ailes also
detested him so you find that you find
validation company and the most unlikely
of places this has been good morning mug
club I appreciate a half-asian lawyer
bill Richmond Gerald a audio Wade
quarterblack Garrett we'll get you
checked out dr. choice thank you so much
tune in tonight for I believe is it life
advice we have we have we have something
going on tonight and then of course a
lot of better calm /schedule see you
later
[Music]